This episode of "Shots of Awe"
is brought to you by Norton.
So I'm very passionate
about technology.
And most people
think of technology
as a set of tools that expand
our creative capacity somewhat.
A set of tools that provide
useful services in the world.
But I believe that there's a
hidden dimension at play here.
I believe that there's this
hidden dimension to technology
that's actually metaphysical,
that was explored brilliantly
in the work of Erik Davis
in the book "Techgnosis."
Consider the example of Amber
Case, cyborg anthropologist.
She says every time you
make a telephone call,
a Skype call, you're essentially
collapsing geography,
you're essentially transcending
the limits of space, of time,
of distance.
Your thoughts electrified,
traveling at quasi
the speed of light,
connecting you
with another mind in real time
in a kind of technologically
mediated telepathy, to use
the term by David Porush.
And so these telephone calls,
these techno social wormholes,
reveal themselves to be a
kind of design engineering.
We become the alchemical gods.
Andy Clark, in his book
"Natural Born Cyborg"
says that the mind,
the modern human mind,
actually emerges in the
feedback loops between brains--
these tools that we create and
the environment in which we
create them.
We're thinking through our
iPhones and Samsung phones.
We're thinking on the internet.
We're thinking on the page.
We build the tool, and
the tool builds us.
We are designed by that
which we have designed.
And because we are
coupled to these tools,
and because these tools promise
to be conduits to transcending
our biological
limitations, perhaps we
should be sympathetic
to the reason
that we run in droves to
buy the new smartphone when
it comes out.
We're literally
getting a mind upgrade.
A wet-ware upgrade.
These are not
trivial things, these
are not fashion accessories.
These are mind-ware upgrades.